ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre l'audition de patrick romero
c'est le président de shell france
il est entendu par la délégation
sénatoriale à l'outre-mer sur la
question de la prospection pétrolière en
guyane septembre 2011 la découverte de
grandes quantités de pétrole au large de
cayenne avait en effet suscité à la fois
beaucoup d'espoir en matière économique
mais aussi des inquiétudes en matière
environnementale alors six mois après où
en est on est bien un élément de réponse
avec cette audition
nous souhaitons la bienvenue à nos
interlocuteurs de shell france et en
particulier à son président monsieur
patrick roméo que je remercie d'être
venu en personne présenter le projet
l'exploration pétrolière au large de la
guyane
comme vous le savez notre toute jeune
délégation sénatoriale de l'outre-mer
créé il ya à peine six mois le certif du
président du sénat monsieur jean pierre
bel s'est saisi de plusieurs sujets
d'étude
notre délégation plancher ainsi ce matin
même sur la proposition de résolution
européenne relative à la pêche la marine
afin de pousser l'union européenne à
reconnaître les spécificités ce secteur
de nous de nos autres maires à la faveur
de la réforme de la politique commune de
la pêche
et c'est cet après midi aux projets de
prospection pétrolière dans les eaux
guyanaises
un autre de ces thèmes d'étude
concernant les faits les enjeux de la
zone des zones économiques exclusives
ultramarines enjeux considérables et qui
nous paraissent de plus en plus
imposants au gré des auditions que nous
menons la délégation a confié l'étude de
ce thème relatif à la zone économique
exclusive à trois rapporteurs dont deux
sont ici présents jean etienne
antoinette sature la guyane et richard
tuheiava sénateur de la polynésie
française
la question des ressources pour son
potentiel de ces zones économiques
exclusives confère à la france grâce à
ces outre-mer le statut de deuxième
puissance maritime mondiale et est bien
sûr bien entendu crucial la prise de
conscience des enjeux de développement
liés à ce potentiel qui se décline dans
différents domaines ressources
halieutiques énergies fossiles énergies
renouvelables sur sens minérales
stratégiques et lot mais désormais en
marche et la délégation sénatoriale à
l'outre-mer crotty prendre toute sa part
les enjeux sont particulièrement
importants pour nos territoires les
projets constituant autant d'espoirs de
développement alors que le marasme
économique est partout présent c'est que
l'activité le cra marine sur souvent
présentés comme des laboratoires en
matière statutaire comme en matière de
recherche
mais jusqu'à présent elles n'ont pas
récolté les fruits
un axe majeur de tout projet doit donc
de producteurs être de produire
localement des effets structurants et
durable permettant une diversification
économique et le développement des
véritables filières les promesses du
projet pétrolier que vous avez que vous
allez vous présenter doivent se mesurer
à l'aune de cet objectif prioritaire les
perspectives d'un développement
équilibré doivent également ménagé les
garanties environnementales la
biodiversité de l'outre-mer constitue un
trésor inestimable de la publicité et
qu'il faut absolument de protéger
préserver sauvegarder les exigences sont
multiples et les deux des complexes mais
leur nécessaire conciliation et la
condition incontournable du défi à
relever ils vous convient monsieur le
président romeo de nous faire la
démonstration que le projet de
prospection pétrolière que vous portez
répond à ses attentes et à ses objectifs
pour un bon déroulement de la présente
édition
je propose
mes chers collègues qu'une procédure à
cinq séquences chacune comprenant un
exposé liminaire de monsieur le
président suivi d'une change sous forme
de questions réponses
cette façon on peut posséder devrait
permettre d'éviter les redoutent les
audits et favoriser une bonne
compréhension du projet il est bien
entendu que seuls les sénateurs présents
s'ils peuvent s'exprimer à d'ailleurs de
nos interlocuteurs de shell france et
ses conséquences seraient donc une
première - présentation du groupe shell
est la genèse du projet guyanais en deux
la présentation du projet procès du haut
moyen âge ou driller 3 les garanties
offertes en matière de protection de
l'environnement adapte les retombées
économiques locales attendu est enfin en
cinquième position la position les
conditions nécessaires à la conduite du
projet stabilité de l'environnement
juridique et fiscal et si vous venez ce
biais d'accords je voudrais tout de
suite c'est de la parole à monsieur le
président kuyo si monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs mesdames messieurs je suis
vraiment très honoré d'avoir de
l'occasion qui m'est donnée de pouvoir
vous présenter le projet et puis surtout
de pouvoir répondre aux multiples
questions que vous aurez sûrement je
suis accompagné d'une partie de l'équipe
shell soit en france soit basé à cayenne
ce qui me permettra j'espère apporter
des réponses plus précises est certaine
de votre question lorsqu'elles relèvent
plutôt de leur domaine d'expertisé
alors en ligne avec les le programme que
vous avez suggéré
je vais vous faire d'abord une
présentation vraiment très rapide du
groupe shell et de l'historique du
projet rapidement parce qu'il est plus
important de regarder ce qu'il est prévu
de faire et les principes directeurs de
nos activités
alors le groupe shell c'est la plus
grosse société européenne nous sommes un
des trois ou quatre plus grands
pétroliers mondiaux et nous sommes une
très très ancienne société française
puisque nous sommes en france depuis
nous sommes une société beaucoup plus
ancien total par exemple et en 2009 nous
sommes très fiers d'avoir créé la
société shell exploration production
france qui porte le projet dont nous
allons parler
alors avant de parler de prospection
pétrolière je vais quand même prendre le
temps de vous expliquer pourquoi on
pense qu'il est important de parler
pétrole à une époque où le discours et
ans essentiellement orientée sur les
énergies renouvelables et sur le
réchauffement planétaire par exemple
notre activité paraît un peu
anachronique passéiste et je vais quand
même prendre quelques instants
simplement pour vous donner notre point
de vue sur le sujet lorsque nous
sociétés énergétiques faisons nos
scénarios énergétiques à l'horizon 2050
nous nous apercevons de deux choses
d'abord tout ce qui va se passer d'ici
2030 et quasiment déjà écrit puisque les
produits le paysage énergétique 2030 est
le résultat des investissements passés
et qui sont en cours de réalisation
sachant que les projets ont une durée de
vie de 20 à 30 ans par contre lorsqu'on
s'intéresse à 2050
l'avenir énergétique dépend vraiment des
choix qu'on fait aujourd'hui
d'où l'intérêt pour nous de regarder à
l'horizon 2050
et qu'est ce que nous constatons est en
ligne avec de nombreux
organisme 1 que la demande va énormément
augmenter alors en fonction des
scénarios elle augmente plus ou moins
mais la demande énergétique peut doubler
d'ici 2050 et c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas innocent puisque ça veut dire
qu'en 35 ans il faut produire une
capacité énergétique équivalente à ce
qu'on a produit depuis le 19e siècle
c'est quand même un défi pour pour nous
qui est très important et ce que l'on
pensait que la production va avoir du
mal à suivre
nous sommes en fait nous pensons à
l'autre d'une période de pénurie
énergétique et qui se traduit par
exemple par une montée des prix de
l'énergie au sens large et donc faire
des choix de production ou une
production d'une énergie ont un impact
sur cette pénurie et nous sommes dans un
univers où nous favorisons toutes les
sources d'énergie donc le pétrolier que
je suis est un immense supporters des
énergies non renouvelables parce que
nous ne savons pas tout fournir donc
nous allons nous a que nous accueillons
avec énormément de satisfaction toutes
les sources d'énergie quelle qu'elle
soit et lorsqu'elles sont nombreux sont
renouvelables
eh bien nous en sommes très satisfaits
mais il faut aussi produire du pétrole
et du gaz
et puis bien sûr ne peut plus produire
de l'énergie aujourd'hui sans prendre en
compte les contraintes de réchauffement
planétaire donc sans se préoccuper des
concentrations en gaz carbonique dans
l'atmosphère
donc nous les choix d'investissement et
de recherche que nous faisons cherche à
répondre à ces trois points efficacité
énergétique pour atténuer la demande
recherche de nouvelles ressources pour
essayer de pouvoir suivre la demande
même atténuées et bien sûr choix qui
sont faits pour réduire l'impact
climatique et pour être un peu plus
précis sur les facteurs clés de la
croissance de la demande est bien il ya
d'abord la la croissance démographique
un monde qui passe de six à neuf
milliards d'habitants forcément est un
appel à la consommation d'énergie vous
avez sur la la cour de droite
l'évolution de la consommation d'énergie
d'un certain nombre de pays en fonction
du produit intérieur brut
voyez que la chine et l'inde sont encore
au début de leur développement
économique et énergétique
si l'inde et la chine suivait les
modèles de la corée du sud de l'europe
de l'eau ça et c'est à vous voyez que la
demande de ces pays
cris pleurait facilement par exemple
donc c'est ce genre de données qui me
conduise à vous dire que la demande
énergétique peut doubler d'ici 2050 et
vous avez à gauche de façon moins
visible mix énergétique alors en verre
tout en basse et de gaz vous voyez que
d'ici 2050 c'est en forte croissance en
rouge c'est le pétrole alors la part du
pétrole dans le mix est réduit il y a il
y a un certain nombre d'années c'était
quasiment 50% voyez qu'en 2050 ce n'est
plus que 30 % 25 % donc la part diminue
mais c'est toujours une énergie
significatif
vous voyez bien sûr l'envolée des
productions d'énergies renouvelables
mais là l'énergie en plus forte
croissance c'est le charbon donc tout
choix que la nation fait de ne pas
produire une énergie sous quelque forme
que ce soit se traduit par quelqu'un un
jour qui produira de charbon quelque
part dans le monde dans une énergie
économie globalisée
donc pour moi il est important pour la
france de produire du pétrole lorsqu'on
a un potentiel géologique pour des
raisons de contribution à l équilibre
mondial de demande énergétique qui ne
phare qui favorise - le charbon et puis
c'est important pour les aspects
économiques balance commerciale etc
je l'évoquerai plus tard voilà ça
c'était mon mon introduction sur les
aspects
demande énergétique et production
logique et la guyane c'est un exemple du
groupe shell qui a investi dans une
ressource nouvelle pour contribuer à la
satisfaction de la demande
alors parlons du permis d'exploration de
guyane c'est un très grand permis de 24
mille cent kilomètres carrés donc il
s'étend de je dirais de la frontière du
brésil jusqu'à la frontière du surinam
sur toute la bande en mer je dirais qui
correspond au pied du talus voyez la
zone vert bleu clair qui est le talus
continental profondeur d'eau de l'ordre
de 200 mètres et ensuite le bleu profond
et le permis est sur la zone 2
de pied du talus si vous voulez donc
avec des profondeurs d'eau qui vont
jusqu'à 2000 à 3000 m nous avons foré à
une profondeur d'eau de 2000 mètres
juste en pied de ce talus alors c'est un
consortium qui détient ce permis qui est
composé de shell à 45% de la société
tullow oil à 27 emmy total 25 et
northpet tu as deux ennemis et j'ai
l'honneur donc de représenter celle qui
est aussi l'opérateur du programme et
qui est donc le porte parole et le
leader je dirais du consortium
alors ceci depuis le 1er février 2012 et
le permis a été prorogée en fin d'année
2011 jusqu'en juin 2016 avec une
obligation pour nous de faire un certain
nombre d'activités de forage et
d'acquisition de données sismiques donc
le sens du programme que je vais vous
présenter est aussi une réponse
contractuels à notre pension de famille
qui exige de nous que nous déployons un
certain nombre de moyens alors quelle
est l'actualité du projet nous avons
donc déposé de déclaration d'ouverture
de travaux pour pouvoir mener à bien les
activités prévues une première
déclaration qui concerne des activités
de forage
donc nous soumettons à l'instruction un
dossier pour quatre forages consécutifs
à partir de juin cette année jusqu'à
probablement joint l'année prochaine la
durée exacte dépendant de la durée de
chaque de chaque forage et de la
sécurité du séquencement et puis une
deuxième déclaration qui concerne
l'acquisition de données sismiques donc
une unique et un équivalent
d'échographie jeudi à des sous sols pour
la pour acquérir de la connaissance est
détecté des réservoirs potentiels à
explorer alors bien sûr sous ce travail
fait suite au travail déjà réalisé elle
qui a abouti à la conduite d'un forage
en 2011 et à une annonce de découverte
de pétrole en septembre 2011
alors nous ne partons nous avons des
fondations solides d'abord l'expérience
de toute l'activité qui a été menée
auparavant
et puis nous avons énormément collaborer
localement
et donc je l'espère accumuler le maximum
de suggestions et de contraintes et de
la demande pour que ce projet est une
acceptabilité maxime et répondent au
mieux à tous les besoins exprimés
nous avons présenté au public l'ensemble
des données d'impact environnemental
donc nous avons opéré depuis le préfet
avec une transparence maximum qui a
donné l'accès de l'information aux
associations au public évident et
évidemment services instructeurs et nous
avons énormément d'activités de travail
avec les organismes scientifiques les
associations socioprofessionnelles les
associations environnementales pour pour
développer cette base que la baraque
vous avez ici donc le stena ice max qui
est le bateau que nous avons
réquisitionné pour cette campagne
or c'est un batuque 9 qui vit qui vient
de sortir deux chantiers navals en corée
et qui est en route pour la guyane
il doit être au large du cap et devrait
arriver sur zone mi juin ça représente
ce qui se fait de mieux
technologiquement dans le monde du
forage
alors c'est le quatrième bateau d'une
série dont qui laissait pas un nouveau
modèle mais ce modèle est le dernier
type de bateau de forage conçu et donc
est particulièrement adaptée à nos
besoins en guyane il s'appelle ice max
parce qu'il peut aussi foré dans des
eaux froides et dans des zones
glaciaires des zones arctiques ou
antarctique mais qui peut le plus peut
le moins deux ans
et puis il y a en parallèle une campagne
sismique qui démarrait début juillet
avec ce bateau le mv océanique phonix de
la société cgg veritas qui serait sur
zone
de juillet à novembre a donc
concrètement nous sommes en attente
d'autorisation qui nous permettent de
conduire ses activités
sachant que nous commencerions enjoint
le premier forage
alors ce premier forage est un forage
d'évaluation de la découverte annoncée
en 2011
donc nous sommes dans la même structure
de réservoir nous ferons à quatre ou six
kilomètres du premier forage pour
contrôler s'il a effectivement si si le
la couche de d'hydrocabures se prolonge
voilà pour contrôler et pour commencer à
avoir des données sur les volumes et
bien entendu que la suite des activités
dépend beaucoup de résultats de ce
forage
si nos espoirs sont confirmés on est
face à un volume intéressant si le
forage et sec
ben ça veut dire qu'il faut travailler
un peu plus le deuxième forage sera un
forage d'exploration là nous ferons à à
plus de 20 kilomètres du forage actuel
dans une autre cible
aucun autre gisement potentiel donc est
la seule façon de savoir si ce réservoir
est riche en hydrocarbures
c'est de forêt pour aller voir donc
cette année une évaluation donc
construire sur l'acquis pour mieux en
comprendre les potentiels et une autres
explorations pour voir si un autre
gisement potentiellement intéressants
dans la même région et les deux forages
qui suivront seront un peu la
conséquence du résultat des deux
premiers une une poursuite de
l'évaluation éventuellement ou de
l'exploration d'autres cibles qui aurait
été détectée notamment par les campagnes
sismiques nous allons faire cette année
nous avons nous demandons ne pourra
faire quatre forages les deux premiers
sont définies les deux autres leur lieu
exact et leur finalité sera fonction des
résultats de l'activité 2012 là vous
avez ici en vers la zone qui a déjà été
analysé par des
seesmic trois dimensions et vous allez
en violet la zone que nous souhaitons
acquérir cette année dans une zone en
violet au sud est qui en fait la zone
frontalière avec le brésil
donc le morceau non couverts entre le
vert et le brésil et puis vous avez au
nord ouest une deuxième zone en
direction du sénat mais qui restent
encore loin surinam pour bat pour
poursuivre l'exploration du pied du
talus vous avez à peu près en filigramme
sur cette zone le pied du talus
continental
voilà donc d'où l'activité forage et
sismique et sismique c'est important
parce que ça permet de valoriser le
patrimoine de l'aide savoir ce qu'il ya
en sous sol voilà peut-être qu'on peut
marquer un temps d'arrêt ici pour que
louise zapping aux questions sur cet
aspect pour ce qu'il ya de dix questions
posées y at il des questions j'ai roulé
sur la première partie non pas de
questions en wi fi un coût élevé pour
unifier le président merci de me donner
la parole j'écoutais beaucoup de tension
votre intervention qui est excessivement
intéressante puisque vous nous dites que
on est à l'aube d'une pénurie
énergétique dans les prochaines années
pénurie énergétique d'ailleurs qu'il
faut relativiser en fonction du coût de
l'énergie parce qu'on sait bien vous
l'avez souligné que la plus forte
croissance attendue sur le charbon
moi je suis d'un pays d'une région
minière nous avons fermé les mines de
charbon dans notre région
tout simplement parce que le coût
d'exploitation du charbon était trop
cher par rapport à sa revente etc à
khalid et si l'énergie des autres
sources d'énergie voyez leurs prix
s'envoler
peut-être que les réserves de charbon
qui existent actuellement pour être mise
à nouveau à contribution
parce que leur prix d'exploitation
serait tout à fait devenu à nouveau
compétitif donc je comprends fort bien
que vous soyez intéressé par ce
magnifique gisement qui est haut dans
l'écho côté d'eux
à côté des côtes de guyane et on
comprend votre intérêt et on peut que
s'en féliciter
on peut que s'en féliciter en disant la
vérité c'est peut-être une façon de nous
garantir une certaine indépendance
énergétique
mais on est aussi en droit de
s'interroger on est aussi en droit de
s'interroger parce que je comprends bien
vous nous avez dit shell est très
intéressé on a repris une partie de ce
qui était mis en oeuvre par tullow oil
et aujourd'hui shell ses 45% de la
société qui s'intéresse à ces gisements
donc très intéressant puisque vous ne
l'avez dit fort justement que vous êtes
en france depuis 1919 bien avant total
et que si le paysage énergétique
jusqu'en 2030 et écrit jusqu'en 2050 et
les années passent vite
les années passent vite et vous avez
raison de faire de la prospective
mais on est aussi confronté à la dure
réalité quotidienne
or que vous ayez effectivement le souci
de trouver des ressources énergétiques
nous interroge aussi sur quel est votre
souci par rapport à la problématique du
raffinage et vous avez bien compris tout
de suite toujours venir je vais en
revenir au fait que shell qui a été en
france depuis nous avait dit 1919 était
quand même la société qui possédait la
raffinerie de petit-couronne que vous
avez cédé en 2008 au goût petroplus est
que aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation sociale économique dramatique
dans ce secteur puisque la société que
vous avez vendu à petroplus petroplus
est aujourd'hui en situation de faillite
et que comme l'entreprise
petroplus à petit couronne avait 550
employés vous
savez les difficultés d'emploi que l'on
a dans ce pays et partout dans d'autres
pays européens particulièrement mais
bien qu à travers le monde et qu'on ne
peut qu'être inquiet sur l'avenir des
550 employés de la raffinerie dont vous
et il est propriétaire jusqu'en 2008
alors on ne peut pas ne pas s'interroger
puisqu'on est dans la prospective
faisons ensemble un peu de prospective
donc vous exploitez et vous nous dites
si après tout on pouvait vous aider à
pouvoir réaliser votre projet sur le
gisement guyane et disons comme ça pour
simplifier les choses pour que l'on ne
comprenne
on peut nous vous dire mais quand on à
exploiter le gisement guyane quid du
raffinage et où le raffinage et nous on
est en droit de dire puisque vous
possédez vous étiez ancien propriétaire
de légines de petit-couronne que vous
savez que cette usine est relié au port
du havre par andy roddick
un oléoduc donc pour l'alimentation de
la raffinerie de petit couronne
c'est un lieu tout trouvé pour que le
pétrole de cette nappe de guyane arrive
directement et vous savez qu'après quand
on est à petit couronne c'est très
facile de valoriser et de distribuer le
pétrole raffiné peut-être plus du gasoil
puisqu'aujourd'hui on sent bien que la
la consommation de descente de super est
en nette diminution par contre le fioul
et de gasoil et continue à augmenter
donc ma question séduire est-ce que vous
avez réfléchi à cette situation de dire
mais si on avait effectivement une aide
pour pouvoir exploiter dans de bonnes
conditions le gisement guyane et on
pourrait effectivement dans notre projet
envisagé déjà l'heure de le relier avec
la raffinerie de petit couronne pour
apporter la matière première
indispensable au maintien de l'activité
et pourquoi pas au développement de
l'activité de petit couronne est passé
de 550 à plus
d'emploi et ce qui est quand même déçu
j'ai aujourd'hui est plus préoccupant
pour nous donc c'est une chose qui
voulait qu'ils me je vais terminer
simplement ce deuxième question qui est
importante c'est que si par malheur qui
par malheur que chose que je sais pas
envisager la fenêtre petit-couronne
fermé vous étiez propriétaire jusqu'en
2008 il faudra bien dépolluer le site
quel sera votre implication dans la
dépollution du site parce qu'il est hors
de question quand même que la
dépollution du site soit une charge
exclusivement des collectivités
territoriales du secteur à savoir la
région de haute-normandie le la cote des
deux communes de rouen et de petit
couronne
donc voila moi ma question est la
suivante votre projet est ce que vous
envisagez d'être un élément qui pourrait
permettre d'envisager une solution
économique intéressante pour le secteur
de petit couronne où vous avez quitté
une raffinerie lavande à petroplus
d'aujourd'hui en faillite avec 550
milliards risque d'être perdue donc
notre souci c'est de savoir comment
voulez faire et si vous avez une liaison
avec les deux j'étais comme un futur
vers cgo collègues à venise et d'être
plus bref faire plus con sic du pis
aller jusqu'au terme
monsieur le président vous avez été
déroulée sur deux tout la parole sur la
relie à sa relation entre l'exportation
exploration en guyane base
aiguillonnaises et la sphère de petite
couronne
mais qu'ont donc si merci pour votre
question me se séparent donc sur
l'aspect je dirais lien entre l'activité
guyane et l'activité de raffinage en
france
ici on parle d'un projet qui s'il
aboutit produirait du pétrole à partir
de 2019 par exemple 2019 comprenez bien
que c'est très loin donc on ne peut pas
conditionner l'avenir
d'un site aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qui peut se passer peut-être en 2019
gens qu'il faut que nous que ce projet
démontre qu'il a ses mérites que les
quantités les qualités le coût
d'exploitation etc etc est un sens pour
qu'il y ait un investissement de
production ce que j'espère de tout coeur
un porteur de ce projet mais on parle de
2020 donc il n'y a aucune relation court
terme entre les deux dossiers
ça c'est une réalité il est évident que
si c'est un projet qu'on pouvait faire
produire dans deux mois là il y aurait
peut-être une question se pose est donc
la question ne se pose pas dans ce cas
maintenant sur tous les autres aspects
que vous évoquez alors je peux en parler
très largement je pense que ça
n'intéressera peut-être pas forcément le
sujet dont on parle il faut bien
comprendre que ce terrain à une valeur
foncière
vous percevez des pollutions comme un
coup en fait la dépollution c'est un
investissement pour réaliser la valeur
foncière de terrain extrêmement bien
positionné dans une zone
d'approvisionnement de la région
parisienne donc qu'il n'y a pas de
questions de coûts de dépollution la
seule question c'est de savoir comment
quelle quelle est la valeur foncière
comme que le propriétaire du terrain
réalisée par des activités de
dépollution et c'est normalement une
activité assez profitable
voilà un très bien tiré au bottin
président merci de me donner la parole
moi j'avais prévu d'être plutôt dieter
de ce qui se passait aujourd'hui mais la
question de nerim invite à creuser un
petit peu les choses
on aurait pu penser qu alain néri pose
cette question parce qu'il est élu
éventuellement intéressés localement or
il est sénateur du puy-de-dôme je vous
précise que je suis élu du département
de la savoie donc je suis pas du tout
non plus intéressés à titre électorale
si je puis dire mais je suis élu de la
nation
et si je veux intervenir c'est que cette
question que pose
alain néri l'élargît à la problématique
sur les responsabilité sociétale des
entreprises
je vous le dis aussi
moi je souhaite que la commission des
affaires économiques du sénat se
saisissent de ce type de questions et
j'attends avec impatience que
l'assemblée nationale renouvelle ses
membres pour que nous ayons un travail
en commun pour voir effectivement
comment les grandes sociétés qui tirent
leurs activités économiques leurs
profits dans ton se réjouit tous soient
liés aussi un cahier des charges qui
soit beaucoup plus large que l'objet
même de l'autorisation qu'elle demande
mais que puissent être prises en compte
effectivement la nature de ses relations
contractuelles avec l'état mais aussi
comment elle fait face à ses
responsabilités sociétales et pour ma
part je le dis aussi jeu j'attends que
l'assemblée se soit stabilisée pour que
nous puissions collectivement avoir une
démarche pour voir comment ce type
d'autorisation puisse être délivrée
effectivement à des entreprises qui
prennent des engagements à l'égard de
l'activité économique sur le sol
national
et je ne savais pas que la mairie et
posera cette question mais j'étais venu
moi vous écoutez pour savoir si vous
même vous même allez en parler et
évoquer ce sujet mais j'avoue que je
serai très attentif et comme
parlementaire de la majorité
j'aurais l'expression pour que les
choses soient claires à l'égard du
ministre qui qui sera votre
interlocuteur pour dire qu'on ne peut
pas dissocier ce dossier d'autres
présence actuelle ou passée du groupe
shell sur le territoire national il se
trouve que je vis aujourd'hui de
fermeture ou de legs de telles
délocalisations pardon entreprises sur
mon département et que la réponse est la
même de la part des deux groupes
internationaux en disant mais vous allez
faire beaucoup de profits grâce aux
terrains qu'on va vous laisser ne le dit
pas trop qui ne le dit pas trop fille
ciellement ça a le don de vous mettre à
dos tous les élus des territoires
concernés car au-delà de la valorisation
foncière qui est un aspect secondaire
ce à quoi nous pensons les uns et les
autres si le développement et au
maintien de l'activité économique donc
moi je souhaite que y compris sur les
appels d'offre ou une entreprise privée
a besoin d'une autorisation publique
pour exercer son activité
il y ait un critère de responsabilité
sociétale au moins cet entretien nous
aura permis d'avoir ce dialogue franc
pour lesquels moi je demanderai que la
commission des affaires économiques au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale puisse
faire évoluer y compris la législation
car on est certes sur une valorisation
économique
on ne sera certes sur un dossier on
regardera la protection de
l'environnement mais il me semble qu'on
doit aller au delà et je suis finalement
ravi que monsieur neri est aussi posé
cette question à l'occasion de votre
entretien monsieur le président
permettez je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez la société shell mais lorsque
vous vous intéresserez de près aussi
chez vous vous apercevrez que nous
sommes une société exemplaire
donc je n'ai aucun absolument aucun
doute sur le fait que nos engagements
sociétaux historique justifieront très
largement la confiance que nous accorde
au gouvernement donc à ce qu'athènes cup
place d'abord merci monsieur le
président ben je les questions qui
viennent d'être évoqués sont
parfaitement fondées et elle vous
exprime la préoccupation qui est seul
actuellement de la représentation
nationale par rapport aux enjeux du
développement du développement
économique mais je pense que peut-être
il ne faut pas brûler les étapes pour ma
part je sais tu pas grand chose sur
l'industrie pétrolière et donc je
souhaiterais beaucoup monsieur le
président qu'on puisse poursuivre le le
déroulement des questions que vous aviez
proposé pour en savoir plus et je
rappelle en particulier que ce projet
touche un territoire particulier il
n'est pas né ni dans les cévennes ni en
savoie ni il et outre-mer et sur une un
territoire auquel nous sommes très
attachés et pour lequel il faut vraiment
veiller à la conciliation des évolutions
économiques et des évolutions
environnementales
donc pour ma part je souhaiterais en
savoir plus de ce que vous pouvez nous
nous dire sur le projet lui-même est
nécessairement nous reviendrons aux
questions posées par monsieur mairie et
monsieur repentin mais après en savoir
plus
personnellement j'aimerais savoir par
exemple qu'elles sont d'ores et déjà
puisqu'il ya eu des forages les
relations que vous entretenez avec la
population
yanez essais et ses élus d'accord bon
nous arrivons certainement cette
question tout à l'heure je retiens
suggestions mais tout de même pas fait
de et bon collègue charles revêt
base et veuves étaient à venir
jean brevet ou heroes 2 mo de mort parce
que on comprendrait pas que le sénateur
de l'étape
et puisque petroplus est en
seine-maritime et il ya entendu mes
collègues n'interviennent pas et donc
bien sûr on comprend que pour les et
plus de 500 personnes qui travaillent
là-bas il ya une préoccupation s'est
rendu sur place et je crois qu'il ya eu
des engagements de prix me semble-t-il
déjà de la part de deux chaînes et iront
compte bien sûr alors qu'est ce que ça
va devenir c'est ce que l'on cherche à
savoir avec vous je pense très
honnêtement ce n'était pas l'objet bien
sûr de notre réunion d'aujourd'hui et
que peut-être que s'il ya une
exploitation qui se fait en guyane où
ailleurs que ce sera l'occasion de
reprendre les choses
bien entendu je pense que comme le
disait thierry repentin
c'est la mission et que le travail de la
mission de la commission économique de
s'approprier des dossiers comme ça et je
pense que très prochainement on sera
amené à le revoir et qu'à ce moment là
on aura peut-être des réponses plus
concrètes et qui nous prend en compte
directement ce projet mais je voulais le
dire parce que et en mettant à nu il ya
plusieurs places à plusieurs reprises
sur place et ayant compris les
problématiques
je ne pouvais pas être sénateur du
secteur ne pas en dire un mot mais je
compte bien sûr qu'on y reviendra dans
les prochaines semaines parce que
effectivement il ya des attitudes fort
justifié de la part des personnes qui
travaillent là-bas et méheut
si on a la chance que des exploitations
se fasse ailleurs et que ça permette de
trouver des solutions
c'est sûrement une trêve ce serait une
très bonne chose très bien bien je
propose qu'on poursuivre mais je
permettais mois de noter avec
gourmandise monsieur le président vous
propos concernant l'hypothèse favorable
usb3 guyane qui pourrait alimenter les
raffineries de france se veut dire que
l'outre-mer viendrait développer
l'emploi et assurer le développement
économique de l'hexagone s'était pas de
venin de vous permettez quand que
quelqu'un de camaret de d'outre-mer
apprécié ces propos alors nous allons si
vous voulez bien poursuivre dans la
présentation du projet
procédure moyens calendrier et ce projet
de guyane
nous abordons précisément les aspects
sécurité environnement que vous avez
vous avez soulevés et puis je suis à
votre disposition pour évidemment pour
tous sujets périphériques
pendant ma présence est due alors il
faut bien il faut bien d'abord
comprendre que ce genre de projet pour
une société comme la nôtre ne peut être
exemplaire
la priorité numéro une de la société
shell aider ceux de ses partenaires
c'est zéro accident
pourquoi c'est assez simple à comprendre
je n'ai aucune envie personnellement
d'avoir un accident qui coûterait la vie
à qui compte dans le cadre des activités
en guyane
c'est une évidence mieux le dire en plus
on sait tous quel est l'impact
absolument dramatique d'un accident
dramatique sur ceux des victimes mais
aussi dramatique pour l'image de notre
société est dramatique éventuellement
pour la survie même de la société
puisque les coûts et les charges du
périphérique peuvent être de nature à
mettre en danger nos sociétés dont quand
je dis que zéro accident c'est la
priorité c'est une vraie priorité ce
n'est pas un discours de façade
je vais vous expliquer en gros ce que ça
veut dire deuxième point
shell nous recrutons des milliers de
personnes qui sont tous
extraordinairement moderne est préoccupé
par les uns par l'environnement et nous
avons notre sein énormément de militants
d'associations de préservation de
l'environnement donc nous sommes en
ligne avec la société et notre objectif
c'est de minimiser l'impact de nos
activités sur l'environnement
c'est une évidence comment voulez vous
qu'on développe une activité pétrolière
en guyane si les guyanais considère que
ce projet n'ait pas conduit de façon
responsable n'a pas de sens
donc je ne peux moi-même comme à faire
l'ambassadeur de stratégie d' impact
minimum sur l'environnement
je n'ai aucune envie que nous soyons le
pollueur de quoi que ce soit alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout ça
soit un jour la passion qu'il ya les
gens qui ont des préoccupations et les
autres qui essaye de les esquiver
nous avons les mêmes préoccupations sauf
que nous avons une responsabilité de
mettre en oeuvre les moyens qui nous
permettent de vous assurer qu on ait pas
d'accident et qu'on ait un impact
minimum sur l'environnement labeur nous
travaillons sur ces dossiers depuis 30
ans nous avons une énorme expérience de
conduite de ces de ces projets sur
lesquels vous pouvez documenté et vous
verrez que nous avons 20 s'installe à
sion de ce type qui sont irréprochables
et exemplaire dans leur conduite et dans
leurs résultats
et ceci est reportée et auditables
sécurité zéro accident ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il faut faire énormément
de prévention c'est des standards de
conception de construction de conduite
des activités qu'ils soient les plus
strictes possibles en termes de
d'élimination des risques par exemple
dans notre société il est interdit de
conduire avec un portable en service tf1
pour vous dire que ont défini des
politiques qui permettent de réduire le
risque ne considèrent que le téléphone
portable dans le tiercé tarifs tant qu
on l'interdît 7,7 exemple vous pouvez le
dupliquer sur toutes les activités qui
nous concerne ici dans une activité de
forage et de prospection pétrolière
il faut des matériels adaptés des puits
bien conçu il faut des barrières
redondante de sécurité il faut que les
équipements s'ils sont défaillants soit
compensée par d'autres équipements de
sécurité redondants qui donne une chance
que la défaillance n'est pas de
conséquences par exemple le stena s-max
à deux systèmes d'obturateur depuis ce
qui est absolument nouveau dans le monde
évidemment il faut des spécifications
techniques adaptées et mis à jour
il faut que ce que l'on propose de faire
fonctionne et qu'on en est là c'est
ti cul il faut une formation du
personnel il faut que les gens aient les
moyens d'opérer les équipements de
mettre en oeuvre les les conceptions et
les modes opératoires par leurs
connaissances et leurs expériences et
leurs qualifications
il faut des systèmes de surveillance
il faut s'assurer que tout se passe
comme prévu
or en guyane nous disposons de trois
systèmes de surveillance en temps réel
les moyens de surveillance sur bateau
l'équipe de forêt sur place une équipe
de surveillance redondantes à cayenne et
une troisième équipe de surveillance
rayonnante à houston aux états unis
cette équipe aux états unis suit tous
les forages dans le monde et vous en
avez ici la photo donc des gens qui suit
de forage donc il y a trois paires
d'yeux ou trois équipes qui suivent la
même activité en parallèle la priorité
absolue c'est la sécurité pour prendre
le forage de l'an dernier nous avons
nous-mêmes définit des normes
d'interruption des activités lorsque les
courants étaient importants bien que
techniquement nous avions les moyens de
résister des courants importants nous
avons décidé d'être une approche de
principe de précaution si vous devez
donc là et ça nous a coûté un certain
nombre de jours de forage
or le retard ça coûte cher mais nous
l'avons fait parce que c'est notre
priorité
et puis faut une culture de la sécurité
il faut que quiconque à bord ou
quiconque qui surveille ou quiconque
qu'ils soient liés à l'activité et les
moyens de l'arrêter chez nous nous
récompensons les gens parce qu'ils
arrêtent l'activité très important et ça
c'est culturel se développe au cours du
temps c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
impose du jour en main donc la sécurité
c'est d'abord un énorme investissement
en amont dans les standards les
technologies
les équipements la formation du
personnel la qualification la
surveillance et la culture qui dit qu'en
cas de doute on s'arrête et ceci nous a
conduit dans notre société a un
historique je dirais d'accident est
particulièrement exemplaire
ceci dit jusqu'à l'accident bp macondo
nos efforts et est essentiellement
orientée sur la prévention
bp wagon de nous a dit qu'il fallait
aussi qu'on fasse beaucoup d'efforts sur
la partie intervention en cas d'incident
puisque nos risques étaient minimes mais
on a considéré qu'il fallait tout récent
opérer comme s'ils étaient réels donc je
vous ai dit en préambule toutes les
raisons pour lesquelles l'accident est
très peu probable mais attends je vais
vous donner je vais vous présenter tout
ce que l'on fait en cas d'incident en
sachant que normalement nous ne
l'utilisons jamais alors le deuxième
aspect c'est d'environnement alors il ya
une première actes il ya deux types
d'activités il ya une activité sismique
dont 4 d'acquisition de données par une
technique ont fait éclater une bulle
d'air qui génère des ondes acoustiques
réverbérée et là l'image je dirais de
réverbération et comme une échographie
donc une donne une image du sous sol
donc c'est une technologie non
destructive de dons d'acoustique comme
l'échographie ont fait éclater une bulle
d'air l'impact sur les poissons et êtres
vivants en mer peut-être considéré que
même ni jab l'au delà de 200 m est
évident que vous faites éclater une
bulle d'air sur la tête d'un poisson
ayant un problème mais 200 m
la plus de 200 mètres de cette activité
toutes les études indépendantes montrent
qu'il n'y a pas d'impact
je parlais des et puis il ya bien sûr
des animaux qui sont sensibles au bruit
les cdas et pour prendre un exemple
alors ils sont sensibles au risque qui a
un très gros avantage c'est qu'il suffit
de faire un peu de bruit pour qu'il
parte et sont si rapides et donc peuvent
partir rapidement donc donc lors des
quatre réseaux des quatre campagnes
sismiques qui ont eu lieu en guyane au
cours des dix dernières années nous
n'avons pas constaté d'impact
environnemental et
nous ferons en sorte qu'on ne constate
pas dans les campagnes futures
d'abord par un inventaire des risques
qui a été fait par des sociétés
indépendantes et dans laquelle on a
apporté notre propre expérience pour
qu'effectivement on soit sûr qu'on est
répertorié tous les impacts possibles de
façon à avoir des mesures de réduction
de cet impact est donc nous mettons en
oeuvre des mesures préventives
par exemple des observateurs d'animaux
marins indépendant bien sûr des
équipements de contrôle acoustique qui
permettent de détecter s'il ya par
exemple des cétacés des procédures
spécifiques pour démarrer l'opération
très progressivement faisant des bruits
légers puis de pluie au niveau sonore
requis par l'activité est bien sûr qu'on
s'arrête lorsqu'il y a
c'est là c'est ce qui se fait de partout
dans le monde au mieux dans le monde et
qui permet de minimiser les impacts
jeudi que nous minimisons un impact et
nous le mesurons puisque nous nous
équipons pour faire des campagnes de
mesures avant pendant rien après
l'activité sur sur le milieu environnant
vos activités
ça c'était la partie cycle activités
forage
alors bien sûr
nous avons foré au large de la guyane
pendant 260 jours en 2011 donc c'est une
activité qui n'est pas nouvelle
nous connaissons très bien le milieu
pour rester au large
260 jours ceci après des campagnes
d'analysés approfondies et leur de l'ue
premier forage nous avons pu mesurer en
fait il n'y a pas eu d'impact sur
l'environnement
au contraire l'activité de forage a été
a été en fait un dispositif de
concentration de poissons donc c'est
devenu un lieu de pêche et
d'attractivité bio de biodiversité parce
que lorsque vous laissez un équipement
immobile dans l'eau il y a un impact sur
la chaîne écologique plantant qui fait
que finalement on a créé tout un
environnement nous connaissons très bien
le problème c'est les dcp
on n'est plus dans la spa on n'est plus
dans la logique du dcp que dans la
logique inverse il faut minimiser
l'impact environnemental et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pratiquement ça veut
dire ça veut dire évidemment des règles
très strictes
je vais pas vous faire la liste des 100
euros s'assurer que les équipements
fonctionnent des équipements de sécurité
sont testés congères absolument tout ce
que l'on va jetterait en mer qu'on
surveille les bateaux tous
qui on n'éclaire pas directement dans
l'eau pour ne pas créer de pollution
lumineuse qu'on réduit les navettes de
bateaux de services donc l'empreinte
carbone au maximum de l'activité lui et
puis bien sûr qu'on s'équipe en cas
d'incident pour réduire l'impact
environnemental d'un déversement
accidentel l'hydrocarbure une chose
intéressante sur la guyane
ce sont ces courants puisque j'entends
beaucoup de choses de pas de certains
sur les courants les connaît bien
puisqu'on les a on les a connues pendant
62 500 indirects on les a étudiées
pendant des années vous avez ici
une simulation d'un ep d'une nappe d'un
déversement accidentel et son évolution
en fonction des courants présent au
large des couteaux qu'ouvrier la bonne
nouvelle
bonne nouvelle d'un point de vue gestion
et approche c'est que les pollutions
reste confiné en mer par opposition ou
des courants qui amènerait tout sur
cayenne évidemment donc la nature nous
est favorable en ce sens qu'elle nous
donne énormément de moyens de confiner
la pollution en mer évidemment il faut
là la gérer et la combattre est évidente
mais en tout cas on n'est pas dedans on
est dans des dispositions de courant
intéressant et s'il y avait des vents
nord sud qui pousserait la nakba la côte
les courants sont suffisamment fort pour
que ça nous donne beaucoup de temps
d'intervention
alors j'ai parlé de la prévention donc
qu'est ce qui se passe en cas de
déversement d'abord la tactique c'est de
la contenir
sur le lieu de l'épandage de la gérer
proche de la source pour que les uns les
effets négatifs se reconcentrer sur une
zone la plus réduite possible
et puis bien sûr il faut interrompre la
fuite
si c'est un déversement accidentel
un saut d'hydrocarbures jeter à l'eau
bon c'est facile si c'est une une perte
de contrôle d'un puits faut s'équiper
pour arrêter la fête un voile année
confinement de la nappe all ages et
extinction de la fuite à la source ce
sont les deux principes je dirais de
conduite des opérations de lutte contre
une pollution éventuelle
alors la plupart des pollutions liées à
ces activités sont des petites
pollutions
c'est par exemple un navire de service
qui eu une fuite lors de son
avitaillement un film par exemple
quelques dizaines de litres par exemple
est pendu au moment de l'avitaillement
sas donc il en est équipée pour pouvoir
contenir ce genre de de pollution
faibles en quantité
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle les situations
à intervention immédiate ou la pollution
est et faible en contenu et nous avons
tous les moyens pour la traiter immédiat
alors nous avons vous voyez que nous
disposons d'un certain nombre de moyens
d'intervention immédiate navire en
permanence équipés pour intervention
moyens humains et matériels
il ya bien sûr des moyens mêmes appels
sur le bateau de forage sur les bateaux
de service
positionné à cayenne et puis évidemment
mobilisables de plus loin aux besoins et
le ice max le scénariste max un double à
deux systèmes d'obturateur depuis qui
permettent d' interrompre une fuite à la
source le caser chien après si la fuite
est plus importante
il faut s'organiser pour qu'on puisse
amener les moyens qu'on consomme en
permanence
compte tenu des courants et des vents là
le meilleur moyen de confinement de la
daps c'est l'utilisation de dispersants
donc des molécules
et dix places en non toxique qui
permettent de casser des molécules
d'hydrocarbures et qui permettent
d'éviter que la nappe voyage évidemment
ce sont des matières ce sont des
produits qu on disperse et qu'il faut
être capable de refaire le plein donc
une grosse partie de la stratégie
d'intervention c'est de la logistique
d'approvisionnement pour amener les ses
produits dont on a besoin pour disperser
hélas il y a donc avion c 130 à trinidad
et à cayenne il y a
d'autres navires de soutien et il y a
des moyens
georgetown et à trinidad qui sont
également mobilisable pour assurer la
continuité de l'approvisionnement des
produits et matériels dont on a besoin
et puis après si on entre dans le cadre
d'une d'une situation extrêmement
extrême extrême il ya bien sûr tous les
moyens mobilisables dans la région en
région c'est golfe du mexique jusqu'au
brésil et depuis l'europe etc
alors je ne vais pas des peu plus ce que
je pense que vos questions permettront
d'apporter d'éclaircir les nombreux
points laissés dans l'eau - mourir si
votre marchand de l'eau merci monsieur
le président monsieur merci de vos
explications
ceci dit j'ai enfin ce stade à ce stade
moi je ne suis je ne suis pas rassurée
je ne suis pas convaincu je suis
sénatrice de seine-saint-denis donc très
loin de la guyane mais je m'exprime
aussi en tant que parlementaire
nationale plusieurs choses d'abord
concernant les risques alors que ti
risque gros risque jusqu'à la
catastrophe possible vous niez pas qu'il
puisse exister je comprends vous pouvez
pas à nier nier nier nier la réalité
vous avez sans doute connaissance de
l'avis du conseil économique et social
environnemental de mars 2012 qui vient
d'être adoptée sur la sécurité des
plateformes pétrolières en mer c'est ta
vie rappelle que depuis 1976 il y a eu
une douzaine d'accidents majeurs
c'est l'effet est
il souligne que le cadre juridique et
est encore très très incomplet aussi
bien au plan international qu'au plan
européen couple un couple en interne et
surtout cet avis fait un certain nombre
de préconisations jeu alors je ne les
énumérer pas tout et je pense qu'au
sénat nous aurons l'occasion de les
entendre et de d'entendre des mondes du
céser puis de les retravailler mais je
voudrais vous interpeller sur
quelques-unes de ses préconisations et
notamment concernant l'exploration
préalable puisqu'on en est là le conseil
économique social environnemental
demande de mettre en oeuvre le principe
de participation du public tout au long
des procédures d'attribution des titres
et des autorisations d'appliquer ce
principe en amont la prise de décision
lorsque toutes les options sont encore
envisageables de recourir à une tierce
expertise
c'est à dire que vous-même fassiez des
expertises c'est normal c'est logique
mais que du point de vue de l'intérêt
général par ailleurs il y à une
expertise indépendante
vu les enjeux ça me paraît vraiment
nécessaire escient c'est l'avis du
conseil économique et social
environnemental de ce point de vue les
informations que j'ai
selon les informations que j'ai il
soupçonnait pas su processus qui est
quitte engagé aujourd'hui
certes il ya eu quelques réunions
d'information du public d'information
mais ce n'est pas la même chose que que
l'association de la population des
associations des élus à la sur le front
sur le fond du du dossier et il ya
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
d'omg de réseau de personnes qui se sont
regroupées qui ont qui ont écrit qu'ils
n'ont jamais on écrit notamment à
monsieur le préfet qui n'ont jamais eu
de réponse et qui ne sont pas convaincus
qu'ils estiment que les risques encourus
sont sont énormes qui pensent que les
moyens en cas de catastrophe
les moyens d'intervention ne sont pas à
la hauteur qui n'ont pas envie en plus
de jouer cette catastrophe et qui
souhaitent être consultés ainsi qu'on le
dit pendant tout le processus et essai
consulter je fais la différence entre
consultés et informés
ça c'est la première chose ma deuxième
interpellation porte sur la question
suivante plus générale je ne sais pas
combien vont coûter c'est cessé ses
recherches et ses premiers travaux
exploratoires
mais tous ces investissements qui sont
qui sont énormes
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il pourrait être
plutôt mis dans
des énergies du futur plus sûr d'abord
dans dans tout ce qui peut être
efficacité énergétique économies
d'énergie mais aussi les énergies
renouvelables diverses qui qui qui
existe aujourd'hui dans lesquelles il
est besoin de m'investir qu'il s'agisse
de biomasse de solaires d'éoliennes
enfin je pense que la guyane et pas de
passe assez bien placé troisièmement si
la bière bio diversité était atteinte
s'il faut bien comprendre mes collègues
tout à l'heure on poser la question sur
le plan économique économique et social
c'est bien les des conséquences
économiques et sociales catastrophiques
qu'encourrait je suis membre de la
commission des affaires sociales et je
pense alors quand on connaît
l'importance de la pêche dans la vie de
la population locale
pas seulement d'un point de vue
alimentaire mais tout ce que sarcelles
comme potentiel d'activité économique et
plus généralement les des ressources de
la faune de la flore
je pense que c'est une question très
très importante et encore une fois avec
des conséquences économiques et sociales
possibles très très forte en terme en
termes aussi d'emplois donc sur sur un
plan social alors vous avez dit parce
que par exemple vous avez dit ce sont
des petites pollutions mais on sait bien
ce que cette petite pollution plus
petites pollutions plus petites
positions
ça fait plus des petites pollutions on a
le même problème dans tout dans tous les
secteurs
on peut poser la fin vous voyez donc à
ce stade
moi il me semble qu'on fait bien d'être
rassuré il est à côté je vais pouvoir
prêter à sa tombe de réponses d'abord
sur l'aspect je veux j'en prends un
point l'aspect consultation information
ça fait un an que je fais des réunions
avec les associations environnementales
de guyane
et j'ai deux types de réactions il ya ce
qui m' et je les ai invités à participer
à la conception de notre app de nos de
nos systèmes à l'élaboration de
non-blancs la réaction ça a été non on
ne veut pas être co responsable donc je
les ai invités à travailler avec nos
équipes sur les mêmes sujets que nos
équipes
alors pour s' donc pour vous dire à quel
point nous serions absolument ravis
d'avoir ces gens là qui amènent leur
énergie positif au service du projet
donc j'attends toujours une association
a claqué la porte dans la commission de
suivi et de concertation scientifiques
que nous avons initié justement pour
développer les connaissances qu'ils
permettent de traiter des sujets
d'impact sur la biodiversité guyanaise
moi je peux inviter accueillir mais je
ne peux pas retenir les gens d'accord
donc si vous avez les moyens vous de
vous assurer que ces gens là veulent pas
et que je serai le premier intéressé est
ravi de sa carte croyez bien que notre
propos je voulais 10 et impact minimum
oxydé gens ont des idées sur la
minimisation des impacts leur ravis sont
les bienvenus deuxièmement sur l'aspect
investissent ma carte je dis qu'on est
en situation de pénurie énergétique
nous pensons et nous pouvons vous le
démontrer si besoin de détente dans une
autre instance
donc je l'accueille avec énormément de
de satisfaction et de joie le fait qu'il
y ait des investissements dans les
énergies en bloc on n'est pas dans un
monde où tout est mutuellement exclusifs
il faut faire et les investissements de
vous parler à beaucoup plus grande
échelle et les nôtres parce que si vous
me demandez de choisir mans entre la
misère économique la misère énergétique
et la misère climatique
je sais pas choisir la misère les deux
sont terribles donc faites en sorte que
vous ayez et les investissements dont
vous rêvez et que vous nous laissez
faire des investissements responsables
qui permettent de réduire ce risque de
pénurie énergétique
donc nous ne sommes pas créateur de
blocage sur le développement de quoi que
ce soit en termes d'énergie je ne milite
pas contre aucune énergie
j'encourage toutes les énergies alors
que d'autres qui parce qu'il souhaite
développer le solaire sont anti pétrole
moi je suis pro pétrole c'est mon métier
mais je suis pro éoliens pro solaire
biomasse et je vous le démontre parce
que shell est un des leaders mondiaux de
l'éolien du solaire et de la biomasse
mais ça ne veut pas dire que je ne je
n'ai pas besoin d'investir dans mon
coeur de métier qui est la prospection
gazière parce que le monde a besoin
d'énergie et je suis dans la situation
je vous dis je devrais que plus heureux
des hommes parce que on s'arrache mes
produits je vous dis non
une situation de pénurie n'est pas
acceptable parce que nous ne devons pas
par nous non choix créer une misère
énergétique importance de la pêche mais
je rencontre les pêcheurs en permanence
nous avons un groupe de travail sur
l'action au maire nous sommes les
premiers à apporter de réponse
structurante
par exemple pour la création de
coopératives pour la pêche à cayenne
pour la réduction de la pénibilité au
travail pour l'établissement de la
connaissance halieutiques sur le plateau
continental et là où on opère mais les
pêcheurs et je pense que nous sommes
nous mêmes gros consommateurs de métiers
de la mer nous sommes des marins nous
avons besoin de marins nous avons besoin
de vous
de tout cela des écoles de formation aux
métiers mal de l'âme de la marine en
guyane qui produit des chômeurs alors et
troisième chose que je voulais vous dire
c'est que nous assumons nos
responsabilités nous n'avons pas besoin
de l'avis du csa pour payer des
conséquences de nos pollutions
donc je vous le dis très solennellement
shell assume ses responsabilités donc si
malgré tout ce que je vous ai dit nous
devions créer deux des dégâts sociaux et
environnementaux nous serions là pour
aider à les gérer
c'est mon engagement et c'est
l'engagement de la société très bien je
remercie monsieur le président je passe
la parole à l'un des rapporteurs
monsieur 3 dette
merci président sous directeur pour
lever toute ambiguïté le prochain tir
avec d'emblée que je fais partie de ceux
qui considèrent que la production aux
forts hydrocarbures constituent un enjeu
historique pour le développement de
notre région
on l'a vu tout à l'heure également en
termes de défis liés reviendra tout à
l'heure un pour l'ensemble de la france
hexagonale
ceci étant dit c'est ton jeu important
nous invite à être très vigilants sur le
milieu de la biodiversité la protection
de cette biodiversité
or il se trouve juste utile ma collègue
l'a rappelé l'ambiance guyane haut
niveau donc du mouvement associatif mais
également des professionnels sur cette
question l'ambiance des mondes que ils
sont exclus des processus de décision et
a juste dit et s'écrit de constitution
notamment au niveau de la charte de
l'environnement que la participation
n'ont pas l'information la participation
est indispensable dans la définition d
différents processus notamment
opérationnel donc la première question
j'insiste est ce que réellement
réellement les organisations les
associations les professionnels
participant cette chaîne de prise de
décision là la deuxième question ça
concerne la gouvernance et un rapport du
parlement britannique 2011 qui stipule
très très clairement que le consortium
pétrolier ont une expertise mme sur
nouveau l'industriel une expertise sur
le volet financier heureusement
d'ailleurs
cependant il ya ya ya ya des
défaillances au niveau de
l'environnement
alors est-ce que à ce niveau la
gouvernance et rééquilibré par rapport
donc à ce rapport qui date de 2011 qui
un rapport relativement récent quand
nous savons tous que ya un vide
juridique au niveau donc du code minier
qui éventuellement refonte du code
international plutôt donc les normes
internationales s'applique plus ou mois
mais créer des zones d'ombré à tel point
que quelquefois ce qui est proposé
d'ailleurs quelques fois sans des
pratiques non conventionnelles dont il
est évident que nous devons nous entoure
et dit prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour éviter à la fois faut
rassurer le grand public
c'est indispensable qu'il son métier
pour concilier justement les enjeux du
développement économique mais la
préservation
de notre biodiversité marine et est
également également donc pour faire
partager donc votre projet de
développement qui qui qui paraît assez
idyllique
la deuxième question par rapport aux la
troisième question apparemment par
rapport au permis de travaux déclaration
de travaux qui aurait été donc déposé
c'est quel type de procédé de forage qui
se rend donc retenu lors de la prochaine
phase d'exploration
vous savez très bien que lors de la
première phase d'exploration il ya un
débat entre vos préconisations et le
mouvement associatif qui était opposé à
tel point que ya prêché il ya un arrêté
préfectoral qui a tranché à ce niveau je
sais que aujourd'hui donc vous revenez à
la charge avec cette fois ci les na'vi
chagrin
l'avis favorable des services donc de
l'environnement lors pouvez-vous nous
répondre précisément par rapport donc la
prochaine phase d'exploration qui va
débuter bientôt quel type de procédé de
forage qui seront donc utilisés d'ici
quelques semaines
toujours dans ce volet technique je
reviendrai je suis moins à l'heure de
l'europe tendue du président sur les
impacts sociaux et économiques
ça concerne donc à une restitution des
risques géomorphologiques suite à la
première phase d'exploration notamment
liés aux études de comportement de la
poésie de ronsard mur par prélèvement
donc est-ce que vous avez ces résultats
est ce que vous pouvez donc vous voulez
publier
et enfin enfin dernière clientes sont à
nouveau les techniques
vous avez dit de vous avez formé de deux
faits ça concerne les histoires de
courant
votre analyse n'est pas partagé par tous
les spécialistes en disant que les
courants sens favorable donc sans
systématiquement favorable à la
production à savoir donc de la côte vers
le large
les espy ciel encore une fois je suis
pas spécialiste mais je jolis coups des
notes qui précise non quelquefois pour
que fois plus souvent que vous ne les
dit il ya des courants contraires qui
vend donc vers la côte
donc ça contrôle dirait éventuellement
ce que vous venez donc d'affirmer tout à
l'heure est enfin là la deuxième
dernière observation
ça ça concerne les principales migration
saisonnière de la faune aquatique
bon je vous ai entendu j'étais un peu
surpris d'ailleurs sur des zones de
guerre une première bien que dans cette
zone et il n'y a pas de poisson
bon j'étais présente et je tape les gens
prier mais bon ça arrive ça arrive
parfois que répondre rapidement
mais bon ça m'étonnerait que dans cette
zone comme par hasard qu'ils n'auraient
pas donc de poissons dans cette zone
alors là encore il faudrait rassurer et
rassurer donc à la fois des marins
pêcheurs mais vous dit que vous êtes
souvent en contact avec eux mais assurez
également donc les scientifiques sur
cette question nantes notamment par
rapport aux dents comme hôtesse qui vont
débuter dans quelques biens tôt donc
d'ici quelques semaines
est-ce que là vous est pris donc des
mesures particulières justement pour
éviter donc ces dégâts est ce que vous
vous phase est donc expérimental vont
tenir compte de ces migrations de la
faune aquatique on sait très bien que
dans les parages il nous faire une
fameuses tortues un compte qu'on trouve
exclusivement dans cette zone durant une
période de de la saison ce sera durant
cette période de quatre qui a débuté
d'ailleurs d'avril jusqu'au mois d'août
donc est-ce que vous allez tenir quand
donc de ces phénomènes
voilà un président qui en fait une
dernière question mais qui va nous
permettre peut-être de rebondir alors on
a parlé de la phase d'exploration mais
vous avez quelques idées sur la phase
d'exploitation ce que vous vous avez une
idée plus ou moins précise à quelques
bars et près du de la quantité du
gisement des gains attendus
george est preneur sous son gilet
répondre à vos questions dans l'ordre
inverse pour pouvoir finir par la
gouvernance qui est qui et reprises un
chapitre d'abord monsieur le sénateur
nous essayons de travailler avec des
données pas des sentiments des données
sur les courants c'est un la donnée de
courantologie est fondamental dans la
conduite de nos activités nous sommes
des marins nous devons connaître les
courants pour faire des conception de
systèmes des choix de matériel comme le
stena et max savoir comment positionner
des moyens d'intervention
c'est notre coeur de métier donc nous ne
pouvons l'engager que ce nous avons des
données sur les cours donc nous sommes
parmi les gens qui ont qui avons fait le
plus de recherches sur les courants au
large de la guyane et nous avons fait
énormément de relever et nous sommes
restés de 160 go en mer donc les
courants ont les erreurs par heure au
jour le jour sur quasiment une année
il est vrai qu'ils n'ont que les
courants ne sont pas 365 jours
exactement comme je voulais des crimes
et ils sont très largement comme ça et
il ya toujours la circonstance
particulière qui peut faire qu'ils sont
pas regardées comme ça elle existe mais
je ne peux pas laisser dire à certains
que les courants vont systématiquement
sur cayenne comme quand on a relevé une
fois dans l'année
c'est la fin de cette audition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi si vous souhaitez
revoir les travaux de la délégation
sénatoriale à l'outre-mer notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très belle
journée à tous